Luna shield technologies is
commercializing the ability to plate
aluminum out of aqueous systems that has
been considered or believed to be
impossible to do from water this is huge
because it has the potential to replace
all the toxic metals which are out there
I have known about Carnegie Mellon
University because of its reputation in
the amazing work it does in Sciences and
it does in the business world carnegie
mellon university gives you the
environment you knees as i start up the
one thing you don't have is cash they
would provide you the resources that's
that's important plus a tech transfer
office here they were extremely helpful
in sorting out what do I need to get the
license done what are the other folks we
can talk to there is a larger
environment within the Pittsburgh region
which includes innovation works carnegie
mellon university has done an amazing
job in terms of connecting us to these
resources i would say that if I never
had that initial help which came from
Carnegie Mellon I would not have been
able to take the company where it is
right now
you